douche froide pour les républicains dans
la première circonscription des yvelines
à droite depuis 1963 le bastion a cédé
sous la vague de la république en marche
françois-xavier bellamy n'a pas réussi à
inverser la tendance du premier tour où
il avait réalisé seulement 27 49 % des
suffrages contre 42 15 % pour le
candidat de la république en marche
didier baichère malgré une belle
remontée l'homme politique de 31 ans
s'inclinent finalement 2 827 voix
j'espérais au soir du premier tour et
j'en étais convaincu que nous pouvions
rattraper le retard pourtant important
qui nous séparait de notre concurrent
dans marche c'était possible et on l'a
prouvé
on a reçu 7000 voix de plus dans l'entré
deux tours mais on s'arrête voilà sur le
seuil de cette victoire parce que je
crois profondément c'est que nous vivons
un phénomène national sur lequel
finalement on avait bien peu de prise il
suffit de constater les autres scores
des yvelines et de voir que là on fait
le l'un des meilleurs scores de toutes
les yvelines aujourd'hui et c'est
vraiment une fierté
la défaite de françois xavier bellamy
est également un coup dur pour le député
dvd sortant françois de mazières
mais le maire de versailles qui avait
remporté la circonscription en 2012 avec
56% des voix est prêt à travailler a
conseillé le nouveau député
je lui ai proposé tout alors se voir
rapidement passé nous sommes important
de suivre en tant que parlementaire
c'est évident il ya aucune raison à
partir du moment où les électeurs ont
décidé qu'il était le député la presse
ce sont des idées on ne travaille pas
avec lui qu'on travaille de façon plus
positive pour 7 après l'annoncé
officielle dans sa permanence de
campagne place charreaux à versailles
didier béchard analyse avec ses soutiens
les scores dans les différentes communes
dans le détail le candidat l'emportent
de 27 points à montigny le bretonneux et
de 41 points lui en cour à versailles
c'est françois-xavier bellamy qui
l'emportent ils totalisent plus de 60
29% des suffrages
je pensais pas honnêtement versailles
remonterait au temps par rapport à la
semaine dernière mais d'un autre côté la
semaine dernière c'était vraiment une
surprise d'être au coude à coude sur
versailles donc je pense que il avait
beaucoup de gens qui n'avaient pas voté
la semaine dernière donc
très bien pour mon concurrent d'avoir
remonté pour lui à versailles comme ça
ça partage un peu la peine avec lui
après avoir savouré sa victoire dans sa
permanence didier pêcheurs se remettra
en marche dès ce mercredi pour ses
premiers pas à l'assemblée nationale